joining me chairman comr you know my
first question to you is this James
Biden an important character in all of
this we know about the $440,000 check
from James to Joe I know you've been in
talks with his attorney he didn't show
up for his date when he was supposed to
have his deposition do you think he
comes before
Congress I think James Biden will come
before Congress I think we'll eventually
get Hunter Biden look uh we've seen Joe
Biden say that anyone who defies a
congressional subpoena should be held
accountable and they should be locked up
so uh we're going to see if his attorney
general is going to be as aggressive uh
with the Biden family at defying
subpoenas as he was at anyone that was
involved in any of the Trump
investigations but look this is more
evidence every day of the Biden being
involved in schemes that involved
influence pedaling around the world
that's what we found out with the FBI
tapes that no one knew about until this
Washington Post story surfaced on Sunday
you know that's interesting you said you
think you'll get Hunter before Congress
you know he's volunteered to come
publicly in that Open Door session but
you think he'll come for his deposition
eventually I think he's going to have to
he doesn't have a choice this is a
credible investigation uh the
overwhelming majority of Americans are
keeping up with this investigation the
Associated Press which used to be a
respectable news Outlet uh they did have
a poll that showed that 70% of Americans
believe that Joe Biden did something
either illegally or at best unethically
with his family Shady business schemes
the American people want to know what
the bidens did to receive the tens of
millions of dollars that they got from
our enemies around the world that's a
simple question that shouldn't be hard
to answer and through the course of this
investigation not only we found out
about the millions of dollars that
they've taken in from foreign Nationals
we we've also found out that they
disguised a lot of money as loans
there's no record record of of repayment
of any of those loans not only uh
interest payments but principal payments
and if that's the case then they owe
Millions more in taxes so uh Joe Biden
wants to double the size of the IRS to
go after tax sheets he needs to look no
further than the the Christmas dinner
table if he wants to look at look at a
bunch of tax cheets who owe the federal
government money I mean this family
continues to uh think that the law
doesn't apply to them that taxes are
only to be paid by the little working
people and not the Biden family that's
why we're going to continue with this
investigation and that's why that we're
going to have the bidens sit down and be
deposed we have hundreds of substantive
questions that we need to ask them and I
think the the American people deserve
the
answers and you just said it look the
American people a vast majority chairman
comr believe there is something
unethical here now why do they believe
that not because the media has been
telling them the truth in fact the
media's been burying all that you found
but we brought it here tonight let's
scroll this these are 20 pieces of
evidence that you have uncovered you can
find them on house oversight committee's
website Devon Archer told you Joe Biden
is the brand 20 Biden phone calls with
business partners the 2014 dinner with
business partners the 2015 business
dinner with business partners and the
list goes on so how could the president
have told us time and time again he has
no involvements with
Hunter
he said that he said he didn't know any
of these people we found out we knew
them all uh he said he never
communicated with these people we found
out he communicated with every one of
them all the people that sent the bidens
millions of dollars from around the
world who Joe Biden said he never met
with he met with them all he talked to
them he had lunch with them he spoke to
them on the phone they had dinner at
Cafe Milano they flew on Air Force 2 he
has not been truthful with the American
people and why is that this is a simple
question what did you do to re received
the tens of millions of dollars from our
enemies around the world and then if you
want to go further next question why
didn't you pay taxes on it what you're
calling
loans have you made any payments on
these loans are they loans or did you
disguise them as loans so you wouldn't
have to report them to the IRS you know
there are so many questions here and you
look at the evidence and I appreciate
the fact that you showed the evidence on
TV when so many in the mainstream media
try to say there's no evidence because
that's what the White House tells them
to say there's mountains of evidence so
why has the president not been truthful
with the American people what were they
doing to receive the money this is an
issue of National Security and I think
every American is concerned that our
president is for sale and you have the
FBI tapes that reveal that uh Joe Jim
Biden was trying to do influence
pedaling with his brother we know that
Hunter Biden was trying to do that this
has been a family business for a long
time and it needs to stop and we need to
know what damage has been done uh
because of the family influence
pedaling you final question for you here
chairman comr I saw Senator Ted Cruz
said that your investigators are working
during the holidays what are they up to
now we're uh we were in Florida today uh
many of our staff interviewing people
that were involved they interviewed the
trustee of the americore health uh
debacle this was one of the the
influence pedaling schemes where Jim
Biden went to a failing Healthcare
company and said if you pay me $600,000
I can use my brother's contacts in the
Middle East and get you all the money
you want they paid him
$600,000 200,000 of that ended up in Joe
Biden's pocket and they ran off they
defrauded that Healthcare company and
Joe Biden was involved in that he got a
third of the of the cut uh this is an
example of what we're going to be doing
we're going to continue to be re
reviewing emails we're going to continue
to be reviewing bank statements bank
statements are still trickling in
because the family had so many shell
companies and so many bank accounts so
we're going to work throughout the
holidays this is an important
investigation we're trying to wrap it up
and I think that uh the support is there
uh through from the American people to
get answers to this
investigation chairman comr keep digging
thank you very much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else